hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going over the second arc of
chainsaw man the psych follows denshi on
his patrolling mission with power which
while they are out takes a completely
unexpected turn for the worse this
results in an extremely intense battle
against the main boss of this section of
the story the one and only bat devil i
really love this arc as it goes to hint
at some of the possible heartbreak and
just top tier writing that we are in for
throughout the later arcs in this story
but just before we do move forward if
you do enjoy anime and manga explain
content but in a story styled format
then do be sure to hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as i intend to try and
cover all of the main and largest
up-and-coming stories before they
release in anime format but anyway
enough of that let's get into the bat
devil arc from the truly enjoyable
series that is chainsaw man
walking through the streets we find
dingy and power are patrolling however
power's having a crisis and screaming
out that she is thirsting for blood she
smacks dingy on the head and tells her
to let her kill something then she
ignores her and instead goes on about
how his issue is how he is going to
touch some of those melons having
recalls what makima had told him that
since power is a fame her horns will
attract attention so the most patrol
places with little traffic and if they
run into other devil hunters or
policemen to show his public safety
badge to them
as denji thinks about his safety badge
he remembers making his speech to him
and power on how the fourth section is
an experimental squad and if it doesn't
produce results their powers might break
it up which would then result in their
deaths as they couldn't find any devils
power boasts it must be because of how
fearsome of a devil she used to be and
how devils run from her ascend denji
then realises that they can't produce
results that way and blames aki for
setting him up with power all of a
sudden power suddenly snaps forward at
the smell of blood and starts running
excited for a fight she jumps from the
building and creates a hammer with the
blood coming from her wrist below her a
fellow devil hunter is seen in a call
telling the headquarters that the scene
is locked down and the civilians have
been evacuated power suddenly flies down
and crushes the sea cucumber devil
sending its remaining pieces flying in
every direction as she stands up she
starts laughing and screaming for people
to gaze upon her glory
later on as makima arrives on the scene
she explains to them that it's an
obstruction of justice when a public
safety devil hunter kills a devil that a
civilian devil hunter had already
engaged with she scolds power and dingy
telling power that she needs to think
before she acts and dingy needs to
control her more makima mentions that
power may not be suitable to be a devil
hunter as she gets excited too easily
hearing there power gets scared and says
that denji told her to kill the devil
dingy and power then start arguing with
power continuing to blame him and then
she's stating that she is a liar machima
then tells them to be quiet and power
instantly freezes with dingy catching on
slowly after
after getting their attention makima
says that she doesn't care who was at
fault but she just wants to see big
things from them later on power sees a
cat and tells denji that she can only
get along with them she hates humans off
instinct because she used to be a devil
but she also explains that she hates
devils because they kidnapped her pet
cat meowi she continues explaining then
makima caught her before she managed to
save her care and that it may have
already been killed but she would still
do anything to get her cat back she
believes that dingy can't comprehend the
feeling she has towards her friend
however dingy states he doesn't care
about cats but mentions that he will do
anything to touch some voluptuous melons
after power hears this she asks dingy
hypothetically that if he retrieved
meowi from the devil for her she would
let him touch her melons initially
surprised at the idea then she
immediately changes his attitude towards
her and gets angry at the devil that he
had kidnapped a poor and innocent kitty
he states that it is unforgivable and as
a devil hunter he will not allow it to
continue and because of this he will
murder that damn devil
after receiving approval from the hq for
day leave it's revealed that power can't
go out on her own and instead always
needs a partner power says that she
knows where they could find the devil
but only denji would be able to fight
him because if the devil sees her it
would immediately use her pet as a
shield hearing this denji mentions the
power that he used to have a pet devil
and that he now lives inside of him but
power finds that idea foolish and says
that it just means pochita is dead and
saying he lives inside your heart is
just their pathetic attempt at
consolation while the two of them sit
there dingy thinks that there is no way
that either of them are ever going to
get along
meanwhile makima meets with the
higher-ups who inform her of the rumors
of the other nations using devils for
military purposes and hope that devils
remain the only enemy for japan and the
future they ask her about her dog squad
and she mentions that she has a
promising one and an interesting one
that she picked out recently before she
leaves though she is reminded by them
that she must not get attached as her
job is just to train the dogs and use
them
back in the car aki asks makima why she
is so interested in denji and she
explains the devils are born with a name
and the more scary the mental image you
have of it the more powerful they become
or the more powerful they are a coffee
devil would be weak as it doesn't have a
scary coronation but a car devil instead
would be strong as the image of getting
run over and dying terrifies people she
reveals that denji can turn into the
chainsaw devil aki believes that that is
interesting but nothing more and
explains that he doesn't have a strong
enough conviction instead he just wants
to live through life idly plus on top of
that he thinks he can get along with
devils pretty much stating in arki's
eyes that he isn't fit for public safety
elsewhere power and dingy arrive at a
distant house on a small hill as they
get closer to the house then she brings
up how she must hide from the bat devil
in power not completely paying attention
slips up asking him if that was the
setting and they confused the mana
because of this dingy realised that
something was not quite right and
attempts to hit power with his axe while
power created a blood hammer however
dingy isn't fast enough and power
manages to avoid his attack and then
hits him on the head knocking him
unconscious power then drags denji
inside the house explaining to the devil
inside that it took her a while to get
outside as she couldn't move freely she
then gives dingy to the bat devil as per
their agreement the bat devil takes
dingy lifting him up and showing the now
awake dingy his missing arm stating that
humans injured him and made him hide but
now he will use this human's blood to
heal he then squeezes dingy like a towel
and drinks his blood regenerating his
right hand but once he drops dingy he
complains of how bad the taste of his
blood was and that he now needs to eat
another human to get rid of this bad
taste inside of the house power tells
denji that humans rarely are foolish for
believing her story
outside of the house now and on the roof
the devil smells the medicine cigarettes
and makeup on humans and decides to go
and eat children as they smell the
nicest which is freaking weird man
inside of the house below him though
power reminds the devil of the deal and
requests meowi back but sadly as
punishment for bringing disgusting blood
the bat devil grabs maoi and places him
onto his mouth deciding to swallow him
as the bat devil swallows meowi power
falls into a flashback and remembers how
she met meowi and named the cat when she
found it it looked skinny but still
tasty so power decided to fatten it up
before she ate it and gave her cow milk
to grow nice and big in time maui and
power started to get attached to each
other making power feel strange as she
otherwise had killed everything that she
had met while lying there on the roof of
a random house sadly the injured bat
devil then appeared and took meowi he
told power to bring him blood or else he
would kill meowing
seeing meowi sin power turns to dingy
and tells him that she now knows how
awful it feels not being able to pat
your pet as he can't pet pochita anymore
the bat devil then picks her up and
throws her into his mouth swallowing her
as well as he notes her disgusting taste
he decides to go and eat some children
to rinse out his mouth while the devil
flies towards the city with he thought
that he will be eating he notices that
dingy is clinging onto his leg and
drinking his blood and telling him to
give him his melons back the bat devil
once again crushes denji's body in his
palm but this time dingy manages to tear
the kill switch on his chest in this
moment dingy recalls how he lost pochita
in the past and they thought that he may
have been eaten by a devil but once he
had found him he was relieved and fell
asleep right on the spot as they crushed
dingy hangs there and the hand of the
bat he wonders more about how power felt
the night meowi was taken by the devil
and as his thoughts continue to race his
chainsaws start protruding from his
forehead as he turns into the demonic
force of the chainsaw devil and starts
cutting into the devil's arm that had
literally just healed dingy chases the
bat devil through the air slashing at
him completely decapitating the devil's
right wing which sends the two of them
crashing through a building as denji
begins to get up inside of the destroyed
building he notices a young female
bystander and yells at her to run away
before she gets eaten
after the girl runs away an anger bat
devil asks why dingy would let a human
get away when he is also a devil however
not answering this question and after
standing up dingy immediately sends
himself flying through the room while
replying that it was so he could split
his belly and touch those melons he
slams and punches the devil's face
launching it through a brick wall and
out into the middle of a busy street as
denshi follows him outside the bat devil
asks aloud if he could cut through this
then proceeds to throw a nearby car at
denji
as the car flies towards the chainsaw
man he stands still not knowing how to
stop the heavy vehicle suddenly though
as he goes to stop the car with his
chainsaws he discovers that he is able
to recheck the chainsaws on his arm and
because of this he successfully catches
the car as the devil admires dingy's
strength he asks aloud why would you use
that strength to save humans but dengue
replies that he couldn't care less about
some guy's stupid life and immediately
throws the car back at the bat devil
slamming it into his face causing the
entire rear of the car to explode the
bat devil though instantly in
retaliation after being hit uses a
sona-like ability that seemingly mangles
denji's body and destroys the
surrounding buildings behind him as the
rubble falls the bat devil picks up the
helpless driver of one of the previous
vehicles in an attempt to eat and devour
him however the dust cloud suddenly gets
blown away revealing the mangled body of
the chainsaw man twisting and whipping
back together as denji takes out his
chainsaws once more his screams enrage
that still even now after being patient
he still hasn't even touched a singular
melon not even once seeing the rage
seeping out of dingy the bat devil yells
at him to stay away however as he tries
to swing at dingy the devil gets
completely outclassed having his head
arm and stomach all cut open or off in
an instant leaving the bat to fall to
the ground completely and utterly dead
inside of the bat devil during a
flashback power recalls how she was
living freely with meowi and eating
animals like cows or beers but then it
all changed when the bat devil showed up
and stole meowi he told her to bring him
a human if she wants the cat to live
flashing forward initially while running
power thought that all lives are trivial
it was merely a cat but then she
wondered why am i running why am i even
searching for a human to save meowi she
then trips and slams onto the concrete
road causing her to think that it was
just a foolish reason
she sits up and realizes that she loves
blood the taste the smell feeling death
and then for the first time recalls
she loves the warmth of the blood and
meowing
in reality with tears in her eyes power
then awakens to see meowi who along with
power has been freed from inside of the
bat devil's guts by a now untransformed
denji confused and half awake she then
asks dingy why he saved her even after
she tried to kill him however a mute
dingy only responds by doing his famous
chest point and melon squeeze hint at
which she remarks that that is a foolish
reason but as she apologizes for
deceiving him she still states that she
will allow him to touch her chest since
meowi had survived as denji tries to
unfreeze his brain he realizes what she
had just said and starts celebrating but
within a second of his fist bumping his
arm is suddenly cut off leaving dingy to
scream in pain as a horrid leech devil
picks up his severed hand in front of
him dingy asks if power can move but she
cannot she tells him to take meowi and
run hearing this though denji decides to
fight the devil he rips on his kill
switch but as his body begins to
transform the saw becomes half stuck in
his head and it is revealed through him
that this state is due to a lack of
blood the leech devil is angry that
denji had killed her boyfriend the bad
devil but upon taking a closer look at
him she sees that denji is cute and
therefore will allow him to live but
will still kill power and meowi as he
hears this though then she spits the
blood from his mouth and prepares to
fight the leech devil he jumps into the
sky still one-handed and swings the
stump towards the face of the devil
immediately though the leech devil
slices dingy multiple times leaving
power stunned at how he is actually
fighting a devil in this date just to
touch some melons dingy manages to block
a blow and punch the leech in its face
however he gets thrown to the floor
straight afterwards which prompts the
leech to question whether the bat devil
had really been beaten by such a weak
person the leech devil says that the
bear and her had dreamed of eating
humans together admitting that it is an
impossible but sublime and beautiful
dream he continues saying that it is a
shame that a cute face like this is
going to die
as he walks forward though dingy
responds confidently that he will not
die before he cops a field to which the
alleged devil responds that that is a
stupid idea and that he won't die to
someone with such a sleazy desire this
leads to denji getting angry as he
thinks about how everyone thinks his
reasonings are foolish and in an attempt
to do damage he lunges at the devil
slicing his face partly with his
chainsaw thinking that everyone looks
down on him for the stuff he does he
challenges their leech to a dream battle
he tells him that if he rips him apart
then that makes his dream worth less
than touching some melons the leech
devil accepts this challenge and the
both of them go to attack with the devil
telling him to beat him if he can then
she tries to get in close and has his
other remaining arm broken still though
he persists he just barely manages to
evade a strike to the face before he
leaps into the sky and sinks this small
section of his chainsaw he is out into
the skull of the leech devil however as
he rips the blade out it is revealed
that their leech devil had stabbed denji
through the torso he goes on to lift the
young hunter up to swallow him while
thanking him for the meal when suddenly
aki hayakawa shows up using his fingers
to summon his utterly insane yet
eye-catching and god damn dope fox devil
which bites the leech's head capturing
it then on aki's orders he eats it and
devours it killing the devil the other
newbies of the fourth squad also arrive
with arki and were then ordered to aid
and evacuate the survivors whilst himino
a senior to aki is tasked to keep watch
for other devils as denji is picked up
by aki he is told that him and power are
to be taken for a debriefing whilst maoi
is to be taken to a veterinarian
hospital free fall check-up denji wakes
up in a hospital bed and sees aki
peeling an apple he tells him that they
found his arm and that it reattached
itself when he got a blood transfusion
also commenting that dingy is really
like a devil then she responds to this
by telling him that he was talking with
a devil himself though aki explains that
this is how devil hunters fight by
making contracts with devils aki states
that he has a contract with a fox devil
he exchanges a part of his body for the
fox's power this time he let the fox
feed on part of its skin for killing the
leech devil aki says their devils always
desire the death of humans and the same
goes for fiends dingy responds though by
stating that power is a good theme
however aki catches dingy and they lie
and states that they caught power and
dingy leaving the patrol area and that
they also found dingy's blood and what
they presume to be the bat devil's
hiding place he asks him why he still
sympathises even after she tried to kill
him during the mini battle over the
apple slices aki tells dinji that if he
further investigated the incident he
would get dingy and power put down but
since there were no casualties aki
states that he would overlook the entire
incident on one condition that dingy
obeys aki's commands from now on he
continues telling him that he's a dumb
kid with no morals and he's been doing
this for much longer than he has so he'd
like to think that he stands for some
sort of social justice so just do as he
says and then you will be able to
protect the standard of life that he
currently has now after a short pause
jinji agrees to this telling him not to
worry as he doesn't have any grand goal
but he will take things just as
seriously as aki does so he can count on
him big time
aki then bows and leaves the room asking
denji to learn to speak with some kind
of respect to which then she says that
he will consider outside of the room
power stands there and handcuffs with
himino by her side power states that she
is innocent and demands to be let go not
sure if this is the right thing to do
hamino asks if it is a wise idea to free
her since if she kills anyone it would
be on aki but as hayakawa frees her he
says that they are devil hunters and
should make use of all the tools at
their disposal though he enforces that
enemies are enemies and they are only
using them with no intention whatsoever
of ever being friendly with one later on
as time flies forward power is seen
entering aki and denji's apartment no
team the cramped place that they have
stunned aki calls mahima asking why and
she responds by saying that she trusts
him more than anyone causing aki to
blush and agree makima tells him that
power said she would be good so it'll be
fine however instantly after the call
ends power is seen to be visibly
disgusted by the vegetables in her food
because of this she throws them across
the room and both denji and aki shout at
her for throwing the vegetables away
telling her that it is extremely
disrespectful
disrespectful to the farmers who grew
them
after eating power states that she's the
type who seldom bathes and seldom
flushes turds she laughs at them for
being so sensitive wondering what the
big deal even is
later in the day we find an anger dingy
who has to clean the toilet himself due
to power
power then enters the toilet and tells
the angry denji that she will now allow
him to touch her chest as they had a
deal and she intends to honor it
as denji looks down on power who's
sitting atop the toilet she asks him
what is he waiting for and to touch away
which causes denji to have a complete
and utter change in emotions calling
power an angel
while dingy shakes power tells dingy
that he gets three squeezes one for
saving maoi one for killing the bat and
third for protecting her from top notch
she reveals that originally she would
have allowed him to touch her melons but
because of what had just happened she
has changed her mind in an effort to
repay his efforts
dingy makes his first squeeze which
makes power blush but weirdly dingy
feels that something just isn't right
and he sees something fall onto the
ground below her power picks them up and
explains that those are her melon pads
which make her overall chest size larger
then she is a bit shocked at the idea
but proceeds either way with a second
and then final squeeze
and as power celebrates that it is over
denji is left standing there speechless
he thinks to himself that he has so many
things he wants to say but overall it
all just fell flat being square now
power tells denji that he is lucky to
touch something so nice and that she
looks forward to working with him in the
future however she continues saying that
she no longer needs to be a devil hunter
as meowi is safe but as she can't escape
mahima she will do her my favor and help
him with his jobs
once she leaves for bed denji stands
there feeling disappointed and empty
later on he does paperwork with makima
who notices that something is wrong with
him he reveals to her that he finally
accomplished a dream of his that he had
been chasing very long time but once he
finally had it in his hands it just felt
disappointing then she now wonders if it
will feel disappointing too for other
dreams he will accomplish and if he
would be happier chasing dreams instead
of achieving them mahima asks directly
what he is talking about and then she
reveals that the first set of melons he
ever touched turned out to be no big
deal which had fallen completely flat of
his expectations for a moment makima
looks at him then she takes his hand and
explains that she believes naughty
things feel better the more you know
your partner as she explains this she
touches his hand saying it's difficult
to understand another's heart so first
take your time studying her hands her
fingers she grabs his hand and places it
on her ear continuing and saying
how are her ears shaped as she bites his
finger she asks if he had ever had it
bitten before
she then tells him to memorize just how
it feels know it so well that even if
you lost your side you'd recognize her
by bite she then grabs his hand and
places it on her melon which makes dengy
blush and fall back in his chair
crashing to the floor
makima gets close to him so close that
they almost make contact and she asks
him for a favor makima sits back in
danger's chair and asks him to defeat
the gun devil
while they confuse denji stands there
she explains that the gun devil appeared
13 years ago and his location is
currently unknown
he is a powerful devil that all the
devil hunters are anxious to kill but
she believes denji is special and would
be able to do it
mahima then tells denji that if he kills
the gun devil then she will grant him
any one wish whatever it be that he
desires
well that officially brings us to the
very end of the second arc of chainsaw
man uh the bat devil arc so if you guys
have enjoyed this video and are you
around here make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video but this arc
honestly is damn amazing and i'm super
excited to see kind of what happens
later on in the story i can see it
setting up to kind of give us some
extremely emotional points that we're
going to you know going to have to like
try and get through later on in the
story here between makima and between
power and denji and makima in between
you know like just all three of them so
far like i don't even know half the
characters that have been introduced
properly yet but i can already feel some
kind of you know heartbreak uh that is
going to happen in the future as i've
been warned from uh plenty of people but
i can see it's setting up for it kind of
almost almost perfectly at the moment so
i'm super excited to actually get more
into this story i'm gonna try and have
the next arc which is the eternity devil
arc uh out by well this time next week
so in the next seven days hopefully
we'll have it out sooner i'm also going
to have another video up uh in the next
few days as well so look forward to that
if you guys are interested it'll be uh
juju kaizen one uh when it comes to the
other explained video arc stories that
i'm doing i'm gonna try and focus on
chainsaw man for a little bit and get a
few arcs ahead so i'm probably going to
you know do the eternity devil arc and
then i think it is the
i think it's the gun devil like after
that i'm not 100 sure i'm not 100 sure
it might be the katana man arc i think
that might be after the
eternity devil i don't know let me know
down in the comment section below i'm
still reading my way through i've just
finished the eternity devil art so i'm
super excited to actually get into it uh
now and like start talking about it as
well which is probably what i'm going to
do honestly after i end this uh
recording right here and honestly i just
want to say thank you for all of the
support recently it has been amazing you
know like no matter what series i seem
to do you guys are still like super
interested and want me to constantly you
know like try and finish that series off
we'll try and finish the series off so
i'm gonna try and you know like do my
best to get them out as quickly as i can
but it's extremely extremely hard with
the amount of editing that just goes
into say like a half an hour video or
like a half an hour long video like this
one so you know i appreciate uh all the
help and all the support that you guys
have been giving me you know over on
patreon and in the comments down on here
so obviously you know thank you to my
patreons as well but uh for now it's
been your professional degenerate divolo
and i will see you all in a bit bye
[Music]